aux objets perdus bien des égarés ne
sont jamais réclamés même de l'argent
dans les coffres des banques des caisses
des assureurs des employeurs petits et
gros montants oubliés attendent aussi
d'être réclamés à la Banque du Canada un
registre des montants non réclamé existe
déjà mais attention il ne contient que
les sommes oubliées dans les
institutions financières à charte
fédérale comme les banques en 2023 le
Nouveau-Brunswick deviendra la première
province de la région atlantique a créé
un registre pour tout le reste chèque de
paye compte d'épargne montant
d'assurance vie prêt à rangement
funéraire certificat de placement
garanti tous ces montants jamais
réclamés devront être transférés à la
Commission des services financiers et
des services aux consommateurs de la
province et si leurs propriétaires ne
sont plus parmi nous aujourd'hui leurs
parenté pourra les récupérer combien
d'argent cela représente on ne sait pas
encore mais si on prend l'exemple du
Québec qui a enregistre comparable 32
millions de dollars sont remis chaque
année à ceux qui se donnent la peine de
chercher au nom de leurs aïeux ou en
leur propre nom alors il y a sûrement
quelques oubliés au Nouveau-Brunswick
aussi passez le mot
[Musique]